hey guys hope you have a great weekend
or to start - one curiosity 180 created
this video on YouTube one of things that
I want to do is start using my YouTube
channel a little bit more to put on
people that are doing creative work
around content and is it evolving of me
and this was an incredible effort you're
about to see tremendous work I you know
based on how many followers they have
and views they're getting their hustle
getting going and so hopefully a bunch
of you can reach out and do stuff with
each other and so it's a little bit of
that old business Sunday kind of thing
where just a lot of fun to put somebody
on who made something amazing guys gals
I love video it's super rad here it is
[Music]
Gary Gary finer finer Chuck then what
vant Vaynerchuk okay Gary Vaynerchuk is
undoubtedly the symbol for hustle
execution and digital advertising he is
the CEO and co-founder of vaynermedia
and an early investor of great ideas
such as tumblr snapchat and Twitter he
is a four-time New York Times
bestselling author and inspires millions
with his YouTube show with the daily be
find out how he achieved his grand
status we have to dive into the origin
story of a young Gary Vee Gary was born
in the former Soviet Union and witnessed
his older relatives being imprisoned and
ostracized for being Jewish in hopes for
a better life Gary and his parents
immigrated to the United States with
very little money Gary's dad made ends
meet by working as a stock boy at a
liquor store
Gary experienced difficulty adapting to
the American culture and was notorious
for being a terrible student
even though education wasn't his calling
he quickly found he had a different
special ability Gary was keen on
observing human behavior he had an
intuitive feeling on what factors
motivated people to buy sell and trade
his introduction to entrepreneurship
started when he was only six years old
he would run to his neighbor's property
hole flowers out of the garden bring
their front doorbell and then sell it
back to them he also had eight lemonade
stands around New Jersey he had his
friends working for him at each of the
locations his major breakthrough came
when he turned 13 and started selling
baseball cards making thousands of
dollars every weekend with a developing
understanding on the concept of supply
and demand
by the time Gary was a young adult his
dad saved up enough money to buy his own
liquor store he made Gary quit all his
other ventures to work for him for
minimum wage Gary work every day and
observed how his dad interacted with his
customers he quickly realized his
expertise in selling baseball cards can
transferred sell wine
he soon became an NFL or a lover expert
of wines when Gary was in college he was
introduced to the internet which was
then known as the information
superhighway Gary saw this as an
opportunity to increase wine sales and
thus winelibrary.com was formed armed
with a vast amount of emotional
intelligence and experience with early
internet projects like wine library comm
and Wine Library TV Gary decided to
create his own digital marketing agency
gary is now the CEO of vaynermedia an
agency that was filled with digital
ninjas who excel in storytelling
branding and marketing however despite
all of his success Gary takes the time
to produce motivational content for
anyone who needs push in the right
direction if you haven't yet we highly
encourage you to check out his channel
where you can find some inspiration for
your journey and hopefully you too can
mold yourself into a legendary
entrepreneur this video focused on Gary
Vaynerchuk in hopes that his hustle and
hard work motivates and inspires our
viewers to go after what they want and
to focus on being happy today in
November 14th is also his birthday and
the launch of his sneakers Gary video
one and double o to bike a Swiss
congratulations and great hustle
hey guys I hope you enjoyed it a lot of
fun pretty good right so this weekend
the Jets have a bye so nothing on Sunday
what do you like to do on your teams by
week
you